Alexei navalny had predicted that the
sentence would be stalinist in its
severity and as he walked into the
prison sport Hall which served as a
courtroom in his case the dissident
opposition leader appeared reconciled to
the inevitable
he looked remarkably relaxed and
exchanged broad smiles and a handshake
with the other defendant in the case
Daniel kolodny the admin of navalny's
YouTube channel
navalny's legal representatives were
welcomed with a wry smile and a hug
journalists had to follow proceedings
via a TV video link but the audio feed
was so distorted it was almost
impossible to make out what the judge
was saying
unusually the sentencing lasted just a
matter of minutes a navalny Shrugged and
smile indicated the outcome a 19-year
prison sentence on charges of extremism
his fifth criminal conviction so far in
a judicial process which his supporters
say is a deliberate Kremlin strategy to
silence one of President Putin's
fiercest critics the sentence is not for
him it is for Russian people who witness
him and see what is happening to him
Putin is trying to frighten as many
Alexis supporters as he can so this
enormous term he has only one goal to
scare as much people as possible
the international outcry was immediate
the U.S state Department described the
19-year sentence as an unjust conclusion
to an unjust trial in a statement the
U.N human rights Chief Volker Turk
demanded that Russia released navalny
and criticized the instrumentalization
of the court system for political
purposes in Russia
the French government also demanded his
release calling the trial judicial
persecution navalny is already serving a
nine-year sentence for a variety of
charges all of which he says are
politically motivated and he still faces
separate terrorism charges which could
add significantly more years to that
total but in a short statement posted
after the hearing the valley said the
number doesn't matter he urged his
supporters to continue resisting and
said I'm serving a life sentence
measured by the length of my life or the
length of Life of this regime
Paul Brennan Al Jazeera